so I want to welcome my China narayan
day a CEO of dobie we Adobe's an
interesting company in a number of
reasons the two that we're going to talk
about in particular today is first of
all they're a major figure in the
publishing industry they have the
creative suite tools so if you're in the
media industry you probably know adobe
is what your designers use InDesign
Photoshop and all that last week they
announced the migration of this to to
the cloud with a Creative Cloud and what
I want to start by asking you as they
sort of beyond the CEO of a big software
company as you recognize the cloud was
where the world was going how did you
kind of work through what it was going
to take to get there what you know what
what would the dangers were the
opportunities the costs I mean this is a
big deal going from essentially a
client-server you know architecture to a
cloud architecture potentially you know
all sorts of things that could go wrong
but clearly the the opportunity was
irresistible so talk a little bit about
your thought processes you did that sure
and you know I think it it really always
starts i heard nike also talked about
the customer and you know we really
tried to say where the customer going
and we just think creation today was
sort of tethered right to a pc and we
thought that the entire creative process
is no longer going to be tethered and
it's going to be one where people want
to you know create wherever inspirations
tried so to speak and you know taking
advantage of tablets is not just
creation devices but consumption devices
and and finally i would say
collaboration it's rare that you put out
something that's really compelling
without having a great way in which to
collaborate and so you know the
engineers and the product people should
have focused on this and said how do we
take advantage of all these things
coming together to reimagine the
creative process and I think that's what
we did with the rollout of the Creative
Cloud and the whole goal chris is really
quite simple it's you subscribe
to the Creative Cloud you get access to
technology as it emerges it frankly
allows our engineers to innovate at a
much more rapid pace because today if
you're on a 12 month or an 18-month
product cycle you're sort of thinking
about when can I get that in the hands
of the customers this just says you know
you get it as soon as it's ready and
you're right the business model changes
dramatically as well because rather than
recognize revenue up front you know this
is more of a pay-as-you-go a
subscription process but we run we run
an experiment in Australia a pilot and
we found that a significant portion of
the customers who came were brand new
customers so I think part of it is also
addressing the next generation of
creators who are far more comfortable
with you know a little bit more of the
uncertainty and ambiguity associated
with the crowd so I think it's exciting
for many many reasons talk a little bit
more about about the business model so
you were in a business so the
traditional business was one where you
would either sell a packaged software
you would sell license and you know
you'd be incentivized to come up with
new versions because there's a new to
opportunity charge the customer now it's
a subscription it's a stream how does
that change your thinking about about
you know how you make money how much you
charge who your customer is that means
you say it's it's a completely different
financial relationship with a customer
do you now release fewer versions more
versions well I think again it was a
multi-step process the first thing we
did was we said let's move to annual
cycles so that you know there's a
regular cadence associated with each of
these products but in general the whole
goal is that once you have access to
this cloud we're in this time I think of
just incredible innovation new operating
systems emerging new tablets emerging
and you know we just found that in order
to keep up with the innovation that was
happening if we stuck to our traditional
12 to 18-month cycles we'd be behind you
know the two people in a garage who were
able to move without having this
traditional desktop model and so people
can subscribe to the cloud we keep your
perpetual option so if you want to keep
the perpetual option and we know what's
the perpetual option the perpetual
option is that you buy the desktop
product the way it is today right
because i think you know until people
experience it they may be folks who say
you know let me play with the cloud for
a while and then I'll move over but we
certainly think the growth is going to
come from the new customer acquisition
through the cloud you know as HTML
evolves we bet heavily on HTML and so we
can say here's the new products we have
two brand new products that will offer
only through the cloud so it's sort of
engaging with our community in a beta
process also to you know get that access
but you're right I think one of the
things that wall street looks at and
says is wow is this going to be
disruptive because you know we had this
model that was well understood and i
actually look at it and say you know it
will increase the amount of subscriber
revenue and rattle revenue that we have
and so over time it actually makes our
revenue stream more predictable what's
the scariest thing that a when you
consider this change what worries you
most what keeps you up at night well we
have to keep innovating right we in
regarding cloud we have to innovate with
regarding the cloud we introduced a new
application for the ipad you know
photoshop touch it was pretty soon the
top grossing app in the imaging and
video category and you've got to just
you know the rapid pace of innovation
that's one of the things and then
getting the message out frankly i think
getting the message out about how this
is different why this different why it's
better for consumers because there is a
huge section of our customer base that's
very accustomed to you know photoshop
comes out at clockwerk i know what to
expect you know and i know how to deal
with that and perhaps you know
enterprises like wired because for you
this is as mission critical as SI p is
for you know the financial part of the
business so making sure that we deliver
the right products for enterprise and
not have hiccups and that you know it is
a change so for people who maybe don't
use the product when people mostly think
about cloud they assume it's rendered in
the browser it's all browser-based is
that is that what you mean by by cloud
now what we mean by cloud is when adobe
you know when when we were in print and
we helped i think revolutionize desktop
publishing what you got was the final
product right and the engagement I think
you know as we were discussing was great
but you really didn't know how many
people viewed it and when the web came
along there was a whole bunch of content
that you were delivering but the
experience was not as engaging it is
somebody like you would want to have and
we thought frankly that this is a brand
new it's a do-over it really is a
do-over for publishers and so how can we
look at not just the content creation
process but the content creation the
content management the content delivery
as well as the content monetization
process and so I think what Adobe's
really embarked on is saying if when the
web came along we are thought of
ourselves also as delivering websites as
opposed to just delivering web pages it
could have been a different company and
we were determined when these new
devices came along that we were not
going to just restrict ourselves to the
desktop content creation process so you
know the value proposition that we have
for a publisher right now is first and
foremost will help you create your
content right because if that's your
brand that's your assets but
increasingly we will tell you exactly
who's been viewing it how many times did
they view it did they watch the ad did
they watch the video what's the math
associated with all of that art as well
we'll help you place the ad and so you
know we're looking at this as frankly a
real natural extension of responding to
what the publishing community needs
let's talk about the new platform in
nearly three years ago we at Conde Nast
and others started talking to you about
how are we going to make digital
magazines on on a platform that actually
didn't exist yet at the time and now
three years in what have we learned what
what have you from the kind of the
authoring tool and you know the software
side what if what if you learned about
the tablet as a new form media well I
first thing I think that we've learnt is
that if people think that this is just
the web on a device I think they are
severely underrepresented the
opportunity that it is in terms of
re-engaging with the community what
we've learnt is that people are spending
more time on these devices then they
have you know on the web they're more
engaged
the spending more and so it clearly is
an opportunity not just to get your
brand out but to deliver money and what
what we are also learning frankly is
that the entire process of getting out
to the iDevices and the Android devices
in the amazon marketplace is still not
as easy as it should be and it will be
but I think what we're learning is that
it's clearly a new medium there's new
monetization opportunities and you know
from our vantage point we have to
innovate to make sure that we can make
the process of laying out all this
content for smartphones and for tablets
and for PCs really easy and so you know
we have we have this entire workflow to
allow people to do that any surprises
well there's some I think again you know
people talk about you know what kind of
information are you able to get as a
publisher to really understand what
Krista to customers are doing the
bandwidth you know so anybody who's
using richness and interactivity I think
there still is a trade-off between being
able to experience that richness and
interactivity versus the bandwidth
required to deliver it on to these
wireless devices so those are things
some of the things that were still
working through you know the ability for
HTML to have the kind of richness that
you would want to have I think that's
still a work in progress each of these
app stores have a slightly different
experience so how do you as a publisher
provide your consistent view you know
and you know because in many ways I
think what we're finding is on the web
as a platform you actually have these
different systems that are emerging and
so trying to mirror the best of the web
and the best of what these platforms
offers is non-trivial you mentioned that
the platform is remember the tap is far
more engaging than the web how do you
know how do you measure that well you
know it's through the analytics software
that we provide and we've done a bunch
of research which shows that adobe is
also in the business maybe if I can
spend 30 seconds you know we bought this
company column nature and we actually
measure 6 trillion transactions a year
or so p
on the web I think what the web provides
as a medium is for you to know exactly
in real time what your customers are
doing and so we are actually able to
only half of our customers measure the
engagement something that was very hard
to do in printed material and the
correlation between what they are doing
on that and then what commerce they're
doing is also known to us so it's clear
that you know one of the things that
these devices have is they have actually
the ability to buy built-in right so now
you know its measurement I you know I
can tell you from an editor perspective
that the world is only getting more
complex we have you know kind of
proliferation of screen sizes and aspect
ratios and pixel densities and operating
systems and e-commerce platforms and
every day there's more of them and it's
kind of you know trying to maintain a
you know high fidelity you know
beautifully designed layout across all
these different things is becoming is
becoming you know more and more
difficult we have this notion that html5
somehow provides this sort of you know
right once read everywhere solution to
this problem are we right is html5 is
the solution well Chris I think all
technology paradigms go through this
incredible pace of innovation where
there's more complexity you know
everybody is tearing their hair out
trying to you know figure out how to
make meaning of this new paradigm and
then I think you'll see a period of
stability and then I think you'll again
see that hectic pace of innovation so I
think we're clearly in the tornado right
now and so I think part of what all of
you know you in the publishing industry
are experiencing is this new platforms
rapid deployment new screen sizes you
know more pixel resolution and we're
working as hard as we can to try and
reduce that complexity so that you can
focus on your content and we can focus
on enabling you to provide that but I do
think you know the pace of innovation
around HTML will eventually you know go
through a little bit of a plateau and
then you'll go through it so hope is on
its way if that's really what you're
what you're looking for so so am you
know Apple famously band flash from its
iOS devices and you've discontinued
flash development in mobile you know
going forward what what fills that role
instead the
this sort of you know the interactive
rich media portable format well first i
think adobe has always been about
whatever is available on platforms will
produce the best tools to enable you to
deliver for that I think you'll see two
forms emerge honestly Chris I think you
will see standalone applications on
these devices emerge and standalone
applications are I think you know
encouraged by some of these providers
because it helps distinguish or
differentiate their platform from the
other platforms that exist but i think
the power of the web over time is in
enabling people to have that same
experience across all of those devices
so HTML will evolve you know we're
certainly as a company taking 20 years
of technology that we've developed for
print and contributing that to WebKit
which you know is the way in which HTML
will evolve and so i think you're
starting to see some incredible rich
animated interactive experiences on
these devices and i think more and more
of that will happen with HTML so it can
work in the browser or it can work as a
standalone application in his in his
final years Steve Jobs took some
relatively a dramatic potshots at at
Adobe and flash in particular what's
your relationship with Apple like now if
you for example how to had a meeting
with Tim Cook to to talk about it will
focus right now and right through the
entire process honestly Chris we agreed
to disagree on certain things but we
worked you know collaboratively another
in other areas i mean we're big you know
fans of tablets being not just
consumption devices but creation devices
you're going to see our entire suite of
applications on these tablet devices as
you know our publishing solutions enable
you know more magazines to be delivered
on the itunes store we deliver more
magazines than any other publisher in
the world through the itunes store you
know we've had tens of millions of
downloaded devices so you know I its
cooperation in the in Silicon Valley in
the true sense you compete in some
places and you cooperate in others let's
talk it we just have an affair where I
guess one more question here before I
turn to the audience but talk about
social you know again one of the you
know in this increasingly complex world
we
now have it we as brands with a media or
otherwise have this need to engage with
people where they are so we if they want
to be on facebook we need to engage
their twitter tumblr Google+ Instagram
you know you name it so much as we have
sort of increasing complexity on the
devices we have complete creasing
complexity in these social ecosystems
presumably this there are many of the
same people but on different platforms
hard to track hard to figure out what
works where you know one of the other
headaches that that the brand managers
have to deal with what you know from
your vantage and you see this and you
have some exposure to it na mature and
beyond is there is there a technological
solution to this or is it simply just
more bodies you know throwing at the
problem well I think there is but you're
right you know my son comes in and you
know I he's a junior in college and he
finds it really frustrating that when he
uses or accesses content on a smartphone
versus a tablet ESPN if he's watching
that it doesn't know who he is and what
it so I think the state of the art will
continue to evolve I think the impact of
social on advertising and the
attribution of it honestly is
underrepresented today because there's
so much activity happening in these
social networks and then people do a
search and the attribution happens so
we're working on both understanding how
to attribute the true impact of social
on commerce through us when you say
attribute what you mean is you know so
the guy who does the search that would
be Google gets the credit for that
search yet it was stimulated by
something in the social sphere and
there's no way to make that link that's
exactly right and so we're focused on
you're looking for a new camera you go
and talk to your friends on Facebook and
and the last thing you do is you look
for that Canon camera that Nikon camera
exactly and so understanding you know
the patterns associated with it so in in
the authoring side we're focused on
social to collaborate and in the
advertising side we're focused on social
to truly understand it and last but not
least all of you who have brands truly
understanding sentiment and so we have a
listening platform that allows you to
really understand not just the volume
but frankly
true insight and sent them into what's
happening in social terrific let me now
turn lights up and turn to the audience
for questions again we have microphones
around any questions for sean's new i
will be a i will i will ask one if I
yeah one up here please I can bring down
here there you go just a quick question
with regards sorry I'm hiding behind the
monitor um just a question about the
paradigm shift that you had mentioned
before so flash obviously changed the
whole landscape in the whole design
landscape html5 has now changed it even
further in light of this what's the
future of flash so I that's a great
question we continue to think of flash
as a great mechanism to really push the
envelope on what happens with richness
with animation with interactivity in the
two areas that we're really focused on
right now premium video you know we're
big believers that all of video is going
to move towards IP networks and being
able to deliver that video and being
able to protect that video and being
able to understand analytics of video
that's a huge area of focus for us
gaming you know there are no reason why
the web also won't just become a
platform not just for casual gaming but
for true rich interactive 3d based
collision detection the whole you know
gaming platform and so we focused a lot
on both of those for PCs as well as on
other screens and you know our goal is
if we can continue to drive innovation
and flash and then contribute all of
that towards HTML we get the ability to
both innovate and then get ubiquity as
well with HTML a follow-up question from
Twitter on that the question of a sort
of a single publishing platform for all
devices I think you had this notion of
liquid layout etc flash was an
originally job I guess was originally
designed as a kind of like one runs run
everywhere is that is that is that
possible do you think that we can
someday after this sort of frenetic
innovation stabilizes see a world where
you really can have a
a single standard that's its effective
across platforms Chris what I would say
is that the a single workflow to enable
you to get that content out to different
platforms we that's absolutely you know
what drives Adobe and so our goal is
with the Creative Cloud and the creative
suite on the client and what we call as
our digital publishing suite which I
know you use as well as others being
able to use that to get the content out
again to all of these different
platforms that's absolutely what we're
focused on and what you mentioned liquid
layout I mean this is Magic we're
creating which is how can you take
content that was designed for one form
factor and then actually get it out in
different form factors so its work in
progress but you know that's that's what
drives us can you say a little bit more
about what liquid layout is how it works
sure today I think when people are
creating publications as you know you
sort of create a horizontal publication
for a certain form factor you create a
vertical publication for that same form
factor and that causes some complexity
because there's file size issues and you
know you have to create that over and
over and over again when a new tablet
device comes the idea behind liquid
layout is really for us to be able to
say if you can lay that out once and
describe the intent of what you're
trying to do as that screen size changes
why can't the software automatically
change it from what it might look like
on a smartphone to what it might look
like on a PC and unfortunately you know
a demo is the best way to do it but
literally what happens is you lay it out
maybe like a web page and then when you
reduce the window size it looks like a
smartphone application right and so what
we're trying to do is use technology to
understand intent and automatically
relay out so let's design and more
design rules that's correct will another
question from the from the audience
there's one at the back there yes siree
yeah thank you good eyes I just look so
talking about the Creative Suite moving
to the cloud is there a new consumer
that you're envisioning that's that's
going to take advantage of this or
or is it mostly existing users that you
see just migrating in that direction and
no again I think that's an excellent
question we think digital literacy and
you know the ability to create all of
this content is just going to be
something that every student you know
will need to do so education actually
ends up being a largest largest vertical
and so we just think that you know
moving to the cloud enables you know
whether it's k through 12 or higher end
to be a huge new audience for for this
not just people who would say creative
creation is what we do for a living but
you know whether they're doing it to
produce a report or a paper there's no
reason why individuals are not going to
use the Creative Cloud to create a
research paper that they put out on the
app store for example and so the idea
behind the Creative Cloud is absolutely
to encourage this whole new generation
not just of what you would call a
creative professional but what we call a
creative anybody who wishes to get their
idea out to be able to use that software
terrific thank you run out of time
please join me in thanking Shannon run
thanks